it's the period text it's an attack on
women
it's an attacks okay true or false
people who have periods spend around
five hundred dollars on tampons over the
course of their lifetime
this is absolutely boss because you can
spend five hundred dollars in a year no
false I think it's a lot more than that
I would absolutely go with false on that
both the average menstruating person
spends around one thousand seven hundred
seventy three dollars and 33 cents on
tampons over the course of their
lifetime
that's just tampons that's not bad
you're right take it over the cramps
I mean that's a lot of trips to
Disneyland I'll give me that this is
upsetting no this thing you just [ __ ] be
done it's okay your Falls like food and
medicine tampons are classified as a
necessity
that's awful big tampon government ones
okay I will say false Oh tampons are
classified by tax law as a luxury item
you know what else considered a luxury
item
tell me boats boats and Rolexes and
tampons this is a boat for your
underpants
are condoms a little more pricey a
luxury item condoms are a necessity
what condoms is not considered a luxury
I don't know are you freaking kidding me
dude I'm pass ma'am this is cheerful in
the state of New York the tampon tax
used to collect five million per year
from people with periods
I believe it I'm gonna say that's true I
mean it's so awful that it's like 1/2
that's a sound money I'm gonna rather
chill are you are you all right I lied
I'm just going against you I don't know
it's like
the state of New York actually collected
seven million per year in tampon taxes
before they terminated it in 2016 if New
York can do it and survive it's okay
Matt rest of America that's just in New
York like that's just one place let's
just think about the whole country
that's crazy taxi anything else man
wants viagra seven freakin million I
hate this game
sure Falls the tampon tax exists in
every country folks are gotta be fault
it has to be false right was homeboys
name was like that that handsome looking
guy bro he's not a sanitation Falls
India Canada and Australia among other
countries have outlawed the tampon tax I
can't love Canada more what a place why
not I get my crazy was so sad during
this you're having a hard time I'm
really having a hard time this is like i
opening your falls in texas the yearly
revenue earned from taxed period
products could buy 10,000 grande
Starbucks coffees so that's total total
yeah and I think I think I'm just gonna
go ahead and say because I think it's a
trick question I think they're trying to
confuse us with numbers I'll say true
the answer is oh my god Texas earns an
estimated 20 million dollars per year
from tax period products which could buy
fast nine million five hundred
twenty-three thousand eight hundred ten
Grande Starbucks coffee how what's your
reasoning what's your political
reasoning for specifically taxing money
and pure disrespect what's the
equivalent to that in a man tax holy
dude that people watching about this do
you think this'll absorb my tears it
doesn't have to be this way we've all
progressive women
this did be free I don't want to be
taxed heinous amounts of money on things
that I need for my body so I can exist
as society would like me to I feel so
bad for you guys it's okay it's okay I'm
not gonna cry but I feel bad
Doug's cry sure